Die heikle Medizin des australischen Brent
entwickelt einen Hund auf der Last, seit Herzen
auf Token über Kanada ein
Eterno-Unternehmen über Vanish Jonathan Safran bauen
vielfältiger Sound Arthritis wahnsinnig alpiner
steilster und am wenigsten engagierter Psalm
Rechtsausleger TAS und eine radikale Kritik an
ihrem Muskeltonus in Hanoi boo hoo ist
keine Schreihals-Entscheidungserfahrung, denn
ich werde immer noch Song David schreiben, aber gemeinsam
Jonathan Safran für hey danke  yadi
gut drohen und stehlen könige nation
frieden in kleiner das ziel, über das ich
spreche, ist ein bisschen kleiner, der titel ist sehr
groß, aber eigentlich ist der inhalt des
buchs bescheiden. ich habe es geschrieben, weil ich
etwas fühlte, das ich viele
leute kenne  gefühlt haben, was ein
Bewusstsein dafür ist, was vor sich geht, absolute
Gewissheit, dass Sie wissen, dass sich die Welt
erwärmt, wie Wissenschaftler uns sagen, und ein
Wissen  der Aktivitäten, die
die Welt erwärmen
, und obwohl ich das wusste und mich darum kümmerte
und obwohl ich die ganze
Zeit darüber sprach, bei Dinnerpartys oder mit
meinen Freunden oder mit meinen Kindern oder
sogar mir selbst, war ich das
alles  ein Leben zu führen
, das nicht meine Werte widerzuspiegeln schien, und ein Leben, bei dem es nicht darum ging
, den Planeten zu retten oder
auf irgendeine
heldenhafte Weise zu zerstören, sondern auf diese winzigen häuslichen
Weisen, diese kleinen Entscheidungen, die
ständig getroffen wurden, wie
ob ich fahren sollte oder ob ich es tun sollte
Fahrrad fahren oder fliegen oder
Zug fahren oder was essen mmm,
also wollte ich
nicht als Wissenschaftler, nicht einmal als Journalist
, sondern nur als Individuum,
das ein geschäftiges Leben führt und das tun möchte
Richtig
Mahon neigt Spoiler Vasu mm hoch Ich höre
Alice Zerkleinerung Pohamba Sie hat
meinen Musselin neben den Oskins ipsec BC
Sargon die Gerüchte in einem Noggin involviert, der
von unserem cm Phelan gebildet wurde, der entwickelt wurde, um
aus der Saga zu lesen, wird E geworfen  mily's unsere
resultierende Ärztin konsultiert oft
Theorien und die Produktion begann und
verpasste sogar einige nicht so gut, um zu
verstehen, wie fest
Nakia sein kann Agnes - merci Valen es ist
der Schnatz, es tut mir leid, mein Sohn, also nenne Simlish
Kraft ein Stock ist meine Arme kann  Erstaunen Sie
mich, Bösewicht, es ist wie bei einem Sushi-Iren. Nun,
zunächst einmal ist es nicht sehr
wichtig, klarzustellen, dass es nicht meine
Meinung ist und es kein Argument ist, das
ich vorbringe, und es ist keine Perspektive,
es ist nur die Wissenschaft und es ist nicht
umstritten  Wenn Sie auch nur ein
paar Minuten auf Ihrem Laptop oder
sogar auf Ihrem Telefon verbringen und sich die
Berichte der Vereinten Nationen über den Klimawandel
oder das IPCC oder so ziemlich jede
wissenschaftliche Studie ansehen, die es gibt, gibt
es einen sehr breiten Konsens darüber, dass
es vier gibt  Dinge, die wir als
Individuen tun, die viel wichtiger sind
als alles andere,
weniger fliegen, ohne Auto leben, weniger
tierische Produkte essen und weniger
Kinder haben, das ist eine der Herausforderungen
diese Dinge sind Dinge, die wir mögen, wissen Sie
, wenn alles, was nötig wäre, um den
Klimawandel zu lösen, darin bestand,
Sie wissen schon, uns nicht mit Messern zu erstechen,
dann hätten wir das schon vor langer Zeit getan
, aber es ist sehr angenehm zu fliegen und
die Welt und ihre Umgebung zu sehen  Es ist
für viele Menschen angenehm, Eltern zu sein, und
es ist sicherlich angenehm, köstliche Lebensmittel zu essen.
Wir wissen, dass tierische Produkte
die destruktivsten Lebensmittel sind, die
wir essen können. Sie verursachen mehr
Treibhausgasemissionen als alles andere auf der
Welt  in der Welt
zusammen und wir wissen auch, wie viel wir
reduzieren müssen und es ist nicht total, wir
müssen nicht alle Veganer werden
dass Menschen,
die in unterernährten Teilen der Welt leben,
in Teilen Afrikas
etwas mehr Fleisch und etwas
mehr Milchprodukte essen, Bürger Europas, Großbritanniens und
der Uni  ted States müssen unseren
Fleischkonsum um etwa 90 % und unseren
Milchkonsum um etwa 60 % reduzieren, um das zu vermeiden,
was die Autoren als katastrophale,
irreversible Klimakatastrophe bezeichneten –
alle Idioten und die Küste hoch
und geben Hausautos
Emission des Anglerfisches Nelda Creme Avanti
Florentine Viet Sünde und unhöflich, wie
sie alle beenden, dies konzentriert sich auf
Wallis phänomenale kleine Extremisten und
ihren sockenlosen Kunda-Gas-Boom, es kommt das
Gefühl, Geschäft zu machen, nachdem im Zweifel jetzt
in Salah in der Nähe des Heimatkerls geteilt wird
Fiat in Werbespots besteht darauf, dass es
Aldi the fr ist oder als Dandy-Gürtel ein
Aaron Sorkin in Zone ist, und haben Sie schon
gespielt, wenn die Inseln die unteren sind
, ist alles ein unendlicher Prozentsatz, und
es ist alles, was dieses World Watch Institute für
erfahrene Waffenclubs ist  draußen in der Herde
ist alles Name und mein Name ist DT für die
Markierung sehen Sie die Verkleinerung
Verschönerungsfresser blinken als eine Bestellung
entlassen Rincon lässt sogar ein Feder-
Rig weg  Einer der Gründe, warum die
Zahlen so unterschiedlich sind, liegt in
den Faktoren, die sie entweder
berücksichtigen oder nicht berücksichtigen, so
dass beispielsweise 91 % der Entwaldung im Amazonasgebiet
auf die
Viehzucht zurückzuführen ist, für die entweder Land geschaffen werden soll
das Vieh zum Weiden oder um
Land für den Anbau von Feldfrüchten für das Vieh zu schaffen, also wissen wir
, dass, wenn wir den Amazonas verbrennen,
viel Kohlenstoff von den Bäumen freigesetzt wird, aber
schließen wir auch die Tatsache ein, dass die
Bäume dies getan hätten, wenn man ihnen dies
erlaubt hätte  existieren einfach, da sie für uns
viel Kohlenstoff absorbiert hätten
, also berücksichtigt die 14,5-Zahl das nicht,
die 51% tun dies, aber in gewisser Weise wird
der Unterschied diskutiert, obwohl der
Unterschied sehr groß ist, mm-hmm, es verfehlt
den Punkt  denn ob es
14,5 oder 51 sind, worüber sich alle Wissenschaftler einig sind,
ist das, was der IPCC in seinem
jüngsten Bericht gesagt hat: Wir können
die Ziele des Pariser Klimaabkommens nicht erreichen,
selbst wenn wir alle unsere Lichter ausschalten,
selbst wenn wir aufhören  Wir fliegen und
fahren morgen nicht mehr. Wir können die
Ziele nicht erreichen, wenn wir die Menge an
tierischen Produkten, die wir essen,
reduzieren. Das anständige Team von Geofeedia zu Hause ist alles Sand unter den
Sets
Jäger, sogar Oktaven
, berufen einen König ein, den sie
jemals gesehen hat. Schriftarten wie
Königreiche, sogar ein neuer Schinken im
Tischstil, Anakin, alles durch den Namen Mensch, es ist alles,
und dieser Club of Rome, der kasachische Tisch,
ist auf Türkisch oft fertig Kasachstan
und co2 ein göttliches  Spark on angesehen in
Porkins das beendete die gemeinsamen
Eingeweide sind zugelassen und AMD c4
träge Par auf den Eisenschemata gleich
weiter und wir sehen uns, wie Sie versuchen, Geld zu verdienen
diese Probleme oder wir haben
keine Hoffnung, also ist es nicht
besser, keine Kinder zu haben, oder es ist besser
, weniger Fleisch zu essen, oder es ist besser, weniger zu fliegen,
oder es ist besser, Sonnenkollektoren zu haben
oder es ist besser, ein Elektroauto zu kaufen. Der
Klimawandel ist ein globales Problem und
es ist ein sehr nuanciertes und kompliziertes
Problem, und die Lösung
muss global und nuanciert sein.
Jeder sucht nach einer
Wunderwaffe  Der
Planet Die Realität ist, dass wir den Planeten
nicht retten und den Planeten nicht
verlieren werden. Zu
Beginn eines Verlustprozesses gibt es
eine Menge Dinge, die wir verlieren werden,
wie einige  Küstenstädte, die
wir verlieren werden, wie Venedig und Miami, die
wir verlieren werden, wir werden
einen Teil des Amazonas
verlieren, wir werden einige Leben durch Waldbrände
und Dürren und Krankheiten
verlieren, von denen wir einige verlieren werden  Jahren durchschnittlicher
Lebenserwartung ist die Frage, wie viel
wir tolerieren können, wie viel Verlust wir
tolerieren können, und das wird davon abhängen,
wie viel Veränderung wir tolerieren können. Wenn wir
also die Überbevölkerung kontrollieren können, werden wir einen
Teil des Verlusts reduzieren, wenn wir
unsere Ernährung kontrollieren können  Wir werden einen Teil des Verlusts reduzieren,
aber ich denke, dass es sehr
verlockend ist, es zu vereinfachen, indem wir sagen,
wenn wir das einfach tun, obwohl es in Wirklichkeit sehr
kompliziert ist,
ähm, das ist Nick Nolte,
Frogadiers Via, die für einen verdammten Dornen auf einer
Oktav-Schwuchtel, besonders in Science
Watts, geklaut wurde  Peter Billy Nine Common Diseases
AG und Hagen erziehen den Stabstisch kann
Miss nya nya erziehen einige
sprechende hochgebildete einige Haut den
Schaden kann ich erziehen vermuten D dort wen
Bitcoin Sophie Stone Balls Hog
initiiert Gefühl Clyde am Fahrzeug
auf den beginnenden Talenten Otis  Angus
Problem Sofaschattierung Hunderte
konkurrieren darum, wer wir bewerten können. Kann das
sowjetische Liefeld-Gemetzel an Val
entkommen und tut mir leid, Problem?
Sachbuch, aber ich denke, seine
Grundlage ist die Psychologie und wie
wir all diese Gefühle
, die wir haben, sortieren können und wie diese sich fühlen  s
Interaktion mit den Entscheidungen, die wir treffen Es
gab eine kürzlich in Amerika durchgeführte Umfrage, die
herausfand, dass mehr als die Hälfte aller
Teenager im Moment Angst haben, sie haben
Angst und sie sind wütend, und ich denke,
dass die meisten Erwachsenen dieselbe Mischung
zusammen mit allen möglichen anderen empfinden  Gefühle, eine
Art Pessimismus, manchmal eine Art
Optimismus, manchmal Wut, Frustration,
Traurigkeit, entschlossen, ein Teil der
Lösung zu sein, und dass diese Art von Mischung
von Emotionen uns in zwei sehr
unterschiedliche Richtungen führen kann, eine ist
eine zu starke Vereinfachung und eine Art
Abwehrhaltung, wissen Sie  das führt dazu, dass wir
uns einfach von dem Problem entschuldigen
und vielleicht andere beschuldigen, dass sie nicht
mitmachen, oder
wirklich nachhaken und sagen, schau, ich bin ein
Mensch und ich esse gerne Fleisch und ich
reise gerne, ich mag mein  Kinder, ihr
wisst, ich möchte Kinder haben.
Ich werde sicherlich
kein ethischer Roboter werden, aber selbst in
der Realität dessen, was es bedeutet, ein
Mensch zu sein, möchte ich so viel tun, wie ich kann, und
vielleicht mein a  Der Berg ist kleiner als der eines
anderen und vielleicht mehr als der eines anderen
, aber ich muss mir darüber keine Sorgen machen,
und das ist zumindest der
Anfang, uns selbst zu betrachten und zu
sagen,
was für mich möglich ist, worauf ich am besten
reagieren kann  die wissenschaft-y
Bunnicula Divya haben oberst al-ghazi
treppen sind mesma London katastrophe viel
besser normann esch grundklassen
konstant alla dampfer vas mission malby
ln die gehackte tomate gehackte espuma
josephus in ewig ist nugget art ok so
ein phalaris eigenläsionen tom eustacia
alle counties  Wer sich darauf eingestellt fühlt, kam heraus, eine
Schwester schickte zuletzt und ein Avalon habesha ein
Interview Kellys Name Togas auf übersinnlichen
rücksichtslosen Treffen Etiketten Metallgriff
Hallo Christian und Schiiten sind dort im
saudi-arabischen Bathurst Handwerker hängt
mitten in der Fotografie Wohnwüste in der Nähe befleckt für Tierschlüssel Zustand Fleischpoon
abscheuliches fleisch verzehrt korallen noch fleisch
reis grab mizwa mugen gefühllos auch
nicht sehen eigenen pina bausch geschäft einen auftrag schon
mal  Ich hoffe, die kontinentale Afrika-Dimension
lernt Elijah, unter ich werde
mir dann einen Flash-Consumer schicken, Ian, bevor ich
zunächst eine Premiere darüber veröffentliche. Es ist deprimierend,
Sie haben Recht und es ist wahr, aber es gibt
zwei Kräfte, die sich gleichzeitig in entgegengesetzte Richtungen
bewegen  Wohlstand und
das andere ist Gewissenhaftigkeit,
also ist Wohlstand der Grund, warum Menschen Fleisch essen,
ein großer Teil des Grundes, warum sie Fleisch essen,
weil es Erfolg
bedeutet, es bedeutet Macht, es kann sein, dass sich diese
Signifikanten ändern, sie
ändern sich sicherlich unter jungen Menschen, die
Sie kennen  Auf dem amerikanischen College-
Campus gibt es derzeit im ganzen Land
mehr Vegetarier
als Katholiken, also bedeutet Fleisch für junge Menschen
für Teenager nicht
Wohlstand und Erfolg, sondern
Verschwendung, Konsum und
Umweltzerstörung, also hoffe ich,
dass sich die Kultur weiter ändern wird
so schnell ändert sich das gerade
und leute die viel geld haben werden nicht
sagen ich will ein steak a essen  In der Nacht werden
sie andere Wege finden, sich wohl
zu fühlen oder, wie Sie wissen, ihren Reichtum zum Ausdruck zu bringen. Als
Zweites würde ich
sagen, dass einige der von Ihnen
erwähnten Länder tatsächlich an der Spitze
der Fleischreduzierung stehen, also China, das
natürlich das größte ist  Land der Welt
hat gerade eine nationale Initiative,
um den Fleischkonsum im ganzen
Land in den nächsten zehn Jahren zu
halbieren, also will China bis 2030 aus Umweltgründen halb so viel
Fleisch essen wie jetzt,
und sie haben alle
Arten von Fleisch mitgebracht  Amerikanische Filmstars,
internationale Filmstars und Regisseure
, die Werbespots machen, die dem
durchschnittlichen chinesischen Bürger sagen, dass wir
weniger Fleisch essen müssen, um den Planeten zu retten,
also gibt es Gründe, optimistisch zu sein,
und es gibt Gründe, sehr, sehr besorgt zu sein,
ob Nebel die Aquazap-
Schwestern sind  individueller mr.  Baucus Mine und
Pie-o-My Sierra Nevada Politik Odin eine
systemische Lösung Otis unser Design für
15 in monogamen Vanessa Mangas wird
in polnischen Politikern gelehrt, die an
Volumen verlieren eine Strafe Nische
kann einen Kuss Latifah auf dem Uno auf
der Last des Zerstörers und der Chinesen bewältigen
Yanbu fördert das, was wir brauchen.
Sie wissen, dass Einzelpersonen die Klimakrise nicht lösen können,
aber wir können
die Klimakrise nicht ohne Einzelpersonen lösen. Daher haben
die Entscheidungen, über die ich schreibe
, Fliegen, Essen, Autofahren und
weniger Kinder haben tiefgreifende
Auswirkungen, die sich wirklich messbar auf die Menschen auswirken
Klima es stimmt auch, dass sie
reale und messbare Auswirkungen auf die
Kultur, auf Unternehmen und auf
Politiker haben, also ist ein Beispiel in Amerika,
als ich dieses Buch vor etwa einem Jahr schrieb,
gab es in dem Land meines Wissens kein Fast-Food-Restaurant
das
einen Veggie-Burger enthielt, den
man einfach nirgendwo finden konnte. Wenn
Sie also eine Fahrt machen, wie ich es oft getan habe,
von New York nach DC, wo m  Meine Eltern
leben und ich habe bei einem Burger King angehalten,
es gibt einfach nichts zu essen, jetzt führt jedes
einzelne Fast-Food-Restaurant im
Land einen Veggie-Burger, einen Beyond-
Burger oder einen unmöglichen Burger, der über
Fleisch
hinausgeht  in den letzten 20
Jahren in Amerika und der Grund, warum
sie diese Lebensmittel servieren, ist nicht,
weil die Regierung gesagt hat, dass Sie
es tun müssen, und nicht, weil die CEOs
gute Leute sind, sondern weil die Verbraucher gesagt haben,
ich will das,
wie wir sagen, wir wollen, dass es sich ändert  der
Markt und wenn sich der Markt
verändert, wird es einfacher, gute
Entscheidungen zu treffen, und so treffen wir mehr gute Entscheidungen,
und je mehr gute Entscheidungen wir treffen, desto
mehr ändern sich Unternehmen und Gesetze
werden beginnen, Gewohnheiten zu folgen, und das
Gleiche gilt für Elektroautos, zu denen
Tesla gerade geworden ist  die größte
Autofirma in der amerikanischen Geschichte, und das nicht,
weil die Regierung gesagt hat, dass
wir Elektroautos bauen müssen, weil es dort eine
Nachfrage danach gibt, besonders bei Zombies mit
Autismus  sind keine konsumierten Einheiten,
oh Honig, markieren die Politik, die Kontinuität,
verstärkte Angst und Boom - Lichter, ein
wirtschaftliches Risiko, handeln sehr oft als
Astoria von allem, was ein Produkt ist, und genießen auch
die Gewinne aus Kunst, und alle hören auf,
die Anrufe zum Kuchengespräch zu bringen
Evangel auf Bank und Iman Kassam fatale
Montoya ist das Produkt Eddie Shari zu
besteigen Cynthia unbelted
Koontz Leine auf Bonnie Miguel Dynamo
Contador Skelett fatale Nandi vor dem
Haus Gesundheitsversorgung von No Heinen und
Herbstmond fatale Webstuhl in einem Hotelzimmer
, das ist sehr Ich brauche eine Ablenkung Asuka  -
Kriminalität Gewalt sogar eine Fassade keine Systeme zur
Milderung von Bullen gut Ich würde das absolut
unterstützen, aber ich würde es anders beschreiben
mm-hmm was Sie sagten ist, Dinge
, die schlecht für die Umwelt sind,
künstlich teurer zu machen. Ich würde sagen,
lasst uns aufhören, sie künstlich
billig zu machen  Sie wissen, wenn ein Hamburger eine
Umweltmaut hat, die jemand
bezahlen muss, wissen Sie, auch wenn wir nicht
an der Kasse dafür bezahlen, jemand
bezahlt dafür i  t jemand zahlt für die Vereinten
Nationen sagten, dass
die Tierhaltung eine der zwei oder drei Hauptursachen für
jedes bedeutende Umweltproblem
auf dem Planeten ist Luftverschmutzung
Wasserverschmutzung Verlust der biologischen Vielfalt
Entwaldung Wer zahlt dafür, wenn es
passiert, tun wir unsere Kinder oder unsere
Enkelkinder werden also, würde ich sagen
, machen wir einfach einen Hamburger kosten,
was er tatsächlich kostet, lassen wir Autos
kosten,
lassen Sie uns Flugreisen kosten, was sie
tatsächlich kosten, und wenn ein Flugticket
von Europa nach Amerika plötzlich
15.000 Dollar kostet, weil es uns wirklich so viel
kostet  und wir fliegen weniger als das ist ein
freier Markt, den die Leute nicht
als Zumutung
oder künstliche
Preisabsprachen bezeichnen, um uns
etwas wegzunehmen  Dass unsere Kinder und
unsere Enkelkinder für
Bücher oder Diamanten bezahlen müssen, ist nicht zuletzt die von
Scofield angesäuerte Iran-Perspektive
Anschließend übersprang und ärgerte Susan
ein integriertes Buch, um zu sagen, dass sie es vielleicht
geschafft haben, ihren Tag mit einer großartigen Küche zu verbringen
Es ist eine
ärgerliche Perspektive, dass es heute einen Film
gibt, in dem die Besprechung
laut ist, und sie mag die Mode von „Nein, du
kommst runter, komm,
so ungefähr 500 oder so Menschen
haben die ganze Erde aus dem Weltraum gesehen, und die
Erfahrung, die sie haben, ist sehr
beständig, es ist so beständig, dass
sie ihm den Überblickseffekt
genannt haben, der ein Gefühl ist, einfach
emotional bewegt zu werden und
die Erde seltsam zu sehen, wie es klingt, wenn
man plötzlich erkennt, dass wir auf einem
Planeten leben, den man sogar so leicht vergisst
Obwohl es das Offensichtlichste ist, was man
sich vorstellen kann, aber wir leben auf einem Planeten, und
wenn Astronauten diesen Planeten aus der Ferne aus dem
Weltraum sehen, neigen sie dazu, zu sehen,
dass er zerbrechlich ist, sehen, dass er
surr ist  Gegründet von einer scheinbar unendlichen
Schwärze, dass es unser einziges Zuhause ist und
dass wir es schützen müssen und diese Art
von Perspektive sie verändert hat, wissen Sie, dass
viele Astronauten zurückkommen und sich der
Philanthropie oder Spiritualität
widmen, und ich denke, dass ich die Erde nie sehen werde
Vom Weltraum aus werden Sie wahrscheinlich nie die Erde
vom Weltraum aus sehen, aber wir haben unsere eigenen
Versionen des Übersichtseffekts. Ich bekomme
es an Silvester. Manchmal bekomme ich es an
meinen Geburtstagen. Manchmal an den Geburtstagen meiner Kinder.
Wenn ein geliebter Mensch stirbt
Diese Momente, in denen wir zurückblicken
und das Leben sehen und uns daran erinnern, wie
kostbar es ist, du weißt,
dass wir vorsichtig sein müssen, weil Tyler
Bargeld gelesen hat. Ich bin Debby, besser, Agnon,
Kosmos, únicos, murmelte ich
familia vota
de naranja vorbei und dies einen moment dann
die meteoritenmaschinerie ist nicht ihre
vision auf anständigen bösen bürger der
riese leicht anziehen so harmlos sprudelnd auch eine
überblickswirkung a  Absolut ja, das ist
genau richtig,
du weißt, diese Person zu sehen, für die
ich mir keine Vorwürfe mache. Ich
schäme mich nicht, zuzugeben, dass ich sie die
meiste Zeit
ignoriert
habe  Ignoriere einfach die Menschen, die du liebst.
Menschen, die sich um
dich kümmern, besonders wenn sie wie Eltern
oder Großeltern sind. Ein bisschen älter. Sie
war die meiste Zeit fast wie Möbel im Haus
, weil ich jung war
und es wollte  andere Dinge tun und
draußen Ball spielen oder mit meinen Freunden abhängen,
warum sollte ich mich mit
jemandem zusammensetzen wollen, der am Ende 80 Jahre alt, 90 Jahre
alt, fast hundert Jahre alt
ist, und diese Art von Gesprächen führen und führen,
aber dann, wenn ich  war
am Ende bei ihr.
Ich sah sie ganz, ganz anders und sah
die Opfer, die sie brachte, und den
Mut, den sie hatte. Das war der Grund
, warum meine Familie überhaupt existierte. Ihre
Geschwister wurden getötet, ihre Eltern wurden
getötet, ihre Großeltern wurden alle getötet
Freunde  getötet wurden Sie war das
einzige Mitglied ihrer Familie, das den Krieg überlebte Das
wusste ich immer, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob
ich das immer gefühlt habe, und ein großer Teil
dieses Buches handelt vom Unterschied
zwischen den Dingen, die wir in unseren Köpfen wissen, und dem, was wir wissen
Dinge, die wir in unseren Herzen wissen,
und wie schwierig es sein kann
, Dinge von dort oben nach unten zu bewegen.
Wir kommen aus Owenton aus denken. Wählen Sie
unser Insulin
aus
Lyndon war passiver Mann
Kenner Hairston zu akustischem Ashish
berührte uns am Handy gute
Verhandlungsunterbrechung genau
als Zahnmedizin Marty und fünfzig
Dollar in fließender Sprache sind haneish PT
Elefanten für
wenn Stella sogar Zoli Shapiro, nachdem
ich neuere Hausbesitzer auf antiken
Ereignissen fertig bin.  McKay und Nikki, sie hat
Drohungen bestanden, und wusstest du, dass es
hoffentlich nicht auf die Jagd geht, bring
es mit, du weißt, ich fühle wahrscheinlich eine
Verantwortung, die der Verantwortung ähnelt, die
du fühlst, du weißt, dass du mich heute hast,
um
über dieses Thema zu sprechen  wenn Sie
Leute mit Themen haben könnten, die viel
sexyer oder lustiger oder attraktiver sind, um einen gelegentlichen
Zuschauer zu mögen, aber es gibt
etwas, das Sie hier lockern, wo
Sie sagten, dass dies wichtig ist und wir
darüber reden müssen, Zeenat, was ich sagen
werde  Ich werde bald mit Ihnen über
Wahlfächer sprechen und darüber sprechen, was sie zu sprechen hat und was nicht.
So habe ich bei einer Lesung, die ich
kürzlich in London gemacht habe, am Ende einer
Lesung immer eine Frage-und-
Antwort-Runde und die letzte Frage
war  von einem achtjährigen Mädchen, das ich bin,
sie saß in der ersten Reihe und sie
fragte mich, ob Sie glauben,
dass wir dieses Problem lösen werden, das den Planeten retten wird,
und ich sagte ihr die Wahrheit, die ist, dass ich
es nicht weiß, und ich sagte  Glaubst du, wir
werden und sh  Sie sagte, ich weiß nicht, ob
wir es rechtzeitig schaffen, und ich sagte, was
denkst du, was nötig wäre, um es
rechtzeitig zu schaffen, und sie sagte, ich denke, wir
müssten immer darüber reden, also ist das Schreiben von
Büchern eine davon  Wie ich über
Dinge nicht nur mit der Öffentlichkeit, sondern auch mit
mir selbst spreche, weißt du, etwas herauszufinden
, ist meine beste Art, sensibel und
vorsichtig mit Material umzugehen, das mir wichtig ist,
und das gilt, ob es sich um einen Roman oder ein
Sachbuch handelt, und natürlich ist dies etwas anderes
Art, darüber zu sprechen, und ich
glaube sehr, was sie gesagt hat, die Klimakrise
beinhaltet Technologie
und darin Geld und Politik und
Werte, aber all das dreht sich um
Gespräche und ob Sie wissen, dass es sich um ein
politisches Gespräch handelt, das die Wähler führen
mit ihren gewählten Beamten oder
ob es sich um ein Tischgespräch handelt
, das wir mit unseren Kindern führen,
wir müssen es im Vordergrund
unseres Denkens halten,
es muss einen so großen Teil
unseres Lebens einnehmen, wie es ihm gebührt  ves, wie das
Ausmaß der Krise Unebenheiten verdient,
Technologie ist Partei, Wirtschaft, Partei,
Politik, Parton's liegen auf dieser Pasta
-Quiche  Auf weniger
neun Personen und dem ethnischen Schmuggelschaden
kann jeder Claudette Colvin Orakelvirus
bedingte mittlere Nennwerte jedes
Landes im östlichen Durchschnitt wechseln, kann ein Rosa
Parks Eric und Rosa Parks T in
Montgomery Alabama und nicht sinn fein
von Finish Alf Gaston erstaunt hoffen
nicht in Busan dies  Handlungsschema wird
ein paar Tipps beigebracht Inman und Tommy Tahiti
Haarspangen mit einem Glanz, der nicht seinen
leidenschaftlichen Moment verriet, es übersprang alle auf den
Trümmern, um voranzukommen, wenn Sie mehr Zitate mögen,
die unter Aushandlung einer Zulassung
zu einer Geschichte von Woody Well, wie Sie sagten,
es gibt einen Jungen  Frau namens Claudette
Colvin, und es dauerte etwa neun Monate, bis
Rosa Parks tat, was sie
Claudette Colvin tat  tat etwas sehr, sehr
ähnliches und weigerte sich, nach hinten in
den Bus zu gehen, und das n-double-a-cp entschied,
dass sie zu diesem Zeitpunkt vielleicht nicht die beste
Sprecherin, die beste Geschichtenerzählerin, die
beste Heldin der Geschichte war,
weil sie 15 Jahre alt war  Jahre alt war
sie schwanger mit dem Kind eines verheirateten
Mannes und sie kam aus einer schlechten Familie, was
man eine schlechte Familie nennen würde, und Rosa
Parks andererseits war ein aktives
Mitglied der ACLU, sie war eine
extrem versierte Strategin und Teil dessen, was  Sie hat
erkannt, dass die Geschichte sowohl wahr
als auch erfunden ist, und es ist kein
Zufall, dass so viele gute
Geschichten Geschichte schreiben und dass so viele ikonische
Bilder und Figuren
in dem Buch historisch werden. Ich sage, Sie wissen schon, mit dem
Christentum
ist es eine Art Witz, aber  Es ist
irgendwie wahr, dass sich ein Gedankenexperiment
mit dem Christentum verbreitet hätte, wenn
Jesus, anstatt an einem Kreuz gekreuzigt zu werden
, in einer Badewanne ertränkt worden wäre, Sie wissen, was die
Leute im September Badewannen um den Hals tragen
würden  er 11. wäre der 11. September gewesen,
wenn diese Gebäude nicht die am
einfachsten zu zeichnenden Gebäude der Welt gewesen
wären, wäre Hitler Hitler ohne
den Schnurrbart gewesen, wäre Gandhi
Gandhi ohne den Lendenschurz gewesen, Barack
Obama hat seinen Namen von Barry in Barack geändert
glaube, dass Barry
Obama Präsident gewesen wäre. Barack
ist so ein kultigerer heroischer Name. Ich
weiß es nicht, aber für uns wird
es offensichtlich, dass es mit dem Klimawandel offensichtlich geworden ist
, dass ikonische Figuren zurückgestimmt werden
müssen
Kazarka bleib
weg von Twitter, schalte das heißeste Potenzial zurück
und sei Veganer, verliere gegen Clayton Valli.
Ich nehme an, du siehst, mein Name ist Liliana Box,
und du weißt, dass er genau so ist,
wie er Asperger hatte, hat diese winzige
Zell-Bhuvana-Follette-Läsionsgruppe, die
zuvor als barmherziger Akt erwähnt wurde  von
buzanis wolke urteil nach unter
angst heißer zigarette kurt's dieses video
auf dem weltwirtschaftsforum in davos genau
11:00 metsu keine zahnlos der dampf
s  auna an die leine zu leinen die haut villa
der stasi in österreich gelagert
die gewohnheit zu verhandeln er beschleunigt
den bus und denkt dimparcio gut fertig zu werden
ich glaube sie unterschätzt ihren
eigenen einfluss sie hat recht und sie hat
unrecht aber ich denke sie hat recht zu sagen  es
- sagen, was sie sagt, sie liegt falsch in
dem Sinne, dass sie Millionen
von Menschen mobilisiert hat und zig Millionen und
wahrscheinlich Hunderte von Millionen,
dass freitags keine Menschen auf den Straßen marschieren würden,
wenn sie
jetzt nicht in Davos wäre, sie würden es nicht tun
in dem Maße darüber reden, wie sie
es tun, auch wenn es Mist ist, aber sie würden überhaupt nicht
darüber reden,
wir sind nichts für sie. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir
jetzt hier sitzen würden,
wenn sie nicht so wäre  Ihr Einfluss
war wirklich tiefgreifend, aber sie hat auch
Recht, dass
es eher um Emotionen als um
Handlungen gehen könnte. Sie kennen Leute, die sich Videos
von Greta Daumenburg ansehen und weinen und
Hoffnung und Inspiration verspüren, als ob dies der Fall wäre  Wenn Sie wissen, was
es bedeutete, ein Umweltschützer zu sein
, sich Videos von Greta Daumenburg anzusehen,
anstatt ihr Leben so zu ändern, wie
sie es getan hat, wissen Sie gleichzeitig, dass
wir Greta als eine Art Heldin hatten, unsere
erste Heldin, von der Sie sagen könnten  In der
Klimakrise haben wir unseren ersten echten Bösewicht in
Donald Trump, und ich habe für Hillary gearbeitet
und wollte, dass Hillary gewinnt, aber es gibt
diesen einen perversen Sinn, in dem ich dankbar bin,
dass Donald Trump Präsident ist,
weil er uns eine Art
Reflexion gegeben hat  von uns selbst ist er die
Verkörperung dessen, was wir nicht wollen, aber wovor
wir Angst haben, und ich denke, er war
wahrscheinlich genauso effektiv wie Greta darin
, Menschen zu mobilisieren, insbesondere junge
Menschen, um zu sagen, genug ist genug,
wir müssen die Welt verändern  unser Hals
auf Lasan Telefon Anika meine Güte das
Treffen von Olivia Kennedy eingebaut sagen Velen in
Sportruhm Sie halten Design-Build und
eine sehr erwähnen Musselin nicht verfügbar, dies
entstand animiert auf c7 dr.
Ausbildung verbessern puritanische Saticons Kunst ist ein
Makel schlag mich um Michonne böse es ist
schrecklich verdammt kurzzeitig werfen typischer
Sturm Netztasche ein Valen Balkan Art
Treibstoff Sabrina ist hier für den Ski
Feldmans jeder Stenka kann auch dieser
Mann ist es hungrig ist frisch Connie super
Jungs, die Abadi sehr  streng gibt
Autonomie zunächst zu hoon Ich vergebe dir einen
Leckerbissen und sogar ein langes Schwimmen ist noch nicht einmal
fertig oft in der Tat verfügbar
gerade einfach Überwachung Aussie
Übersicht Momenta Bestellung Fick durch die
Lachse Bestellung gewonnen passiert in hundert in Ich
glaube nicht, dass es irgendetwas gibt  Das
löst eine Welle aus. Ich würde sagen,
es passiert jetzt, es
passiert bereits, wenn man erst einmal drin ist,
kann es schwer sein, zu erkennen, dass es
passiert, weil es wie der alte Witz
ist, dass sich eines Tages zwei Fische treffen und einer sagt,
aber das  Wasser ist sehr warm und der
andere sagt, was zur Hölle Wasser ist, wissen Sie
, wenn wir uns in einem Kontext befinden, ist
es sehr schwer zu bemerken, aber die Welt
hat sich verändert s  o Vieles im letzten Jahr in
Bezug auf unser Bewusstsein für den Klimawandel,
unsere Bereitschaft, unser Eifer, darüber zu
sprechen, und unsere Bereitschaft und
Eifer, unser Leben als
Reaktion darauf zu ändern, wenn mich jemand vor einem Jahr gefragt hätte
, wurden mir vor einem Jahr gesagt
Glaubst du, dass die Golden Globes vegan sein werden
? Ich hätte nein gesagt, natürlich nicht.
Ich meine, warum sollten sie sein. Denkst du,
dass die Gewinner der besten Schauspieler
auf die Bühne gehen und über die Notwendigkeit sprechen,
um des Willens willen weniger Fleisch zu essen?  der
Umwelt wie Joaquin Phoenix tat Ich
hätte natürlich nein gesagt,
wenn Sie gesagt hätten, glauben Sie, dass Beyond
Meat das erfolgreichste
Unternehmen in Amerika sein wird, hätte ich
natürlich nicht gesagt, wenn jemand gesagt hätte, dass Sie das
wissen  Ein Unternehmen für
Elektroautos wird das erfolgreichste sein. Das größte
Autounternehmen in der Geschichte der Vereinigten
Staaten. Ich hätte es mir nie vorstellen können,
und jetzt betrachten wir diese Dinge als selbstverständlich,
und die Änderungsrate beschleunigt sich,
und ich glaube nicht, dass es b  Wegen
irgendetwas oder einer Person schätze Jonas
das Ende des Feldes, der Momineen
und Rukavina in einer Blase kauft und in meinem Namen seine
eigene Dimension der Freiheitsaugen und
Timothy fühlte, um an Vezes zu glauben, um
für eine gewisse Bequemlichkeit zu fliehen
Geld Nana begann Suresh lebte
monatliche Kosten, so dass ich Ian
auch im Besitz des Staatsrates in
Mono auf Gavin Zoo auf Toast ihm Amanda
und Hawkman Zahn kannte, um auf
Vorräten
zu verschwinden  Motiv
Yulin im Urlaub in Hongkong Gemeinsam ist
das Sundaram-Entscheidungsphilosophenproblem
Vasu Mary Jean David Sie vermissen Raven
Hobbes, genau das sind die schwedischen
Protagonisten in Erst- und
Nischenleben einer Art und Kleinschmidt Unendlicher
Zoo Harbin auch für hinden das en vivo
und Haus für einige  Karte auf dem System,
auch wenn der österreichische Amerikaner Incan distanziert,
ist ein winziger Stern Vorhäute
andris mit assoziierten une die Kinder und
wächst unter dem Laken auf Toast Visioning ist
akribisch  lous
MacLeish Testosteron als SD-Nebel
lichtet sich und wenn wir weinen und seinen Tank holen, ist es
lustig, dass Sie erwähnen sollten, dass, weil
ich mir zufällig den Finger gekratzt habe, ich ihn
nicht dazu bringen konnte, die Blutung zu stoppen, und
es ist wahr, es war alles, woran ich denken konnte
und  Ich war besessen davon, weißt du, ich habe
versucht, anzuhalten, ich habe mit
meinen Freunden gesprochen, oh mein Gott, mein Finger tut so weh,
weißt du, es ist sehr schwer,
die Dinge in ihrem richtigen Maßstab und in
ihrer richtigen Perspektive zu halten, aber vielleicht können wir
es einfach anerkennen  Dass es so
ist, ein Mensch zu sein und Wege zu finden
, es zu überwinden, anstatt so zu tun, als wäre es
nicht die Wahrheit, die man kennt, wenn man in einen
Laden geht und dort etwas ist, das man
mag und das man gerne hätte
, denkt man ans Stehlen  es oder bezahlst du
immer dafür wie ein
Sockenaffe, der die andere Seite zeigt, für die du immer
bezahlst, natürlich hast du mich nicht auch
und warum wie triffst du die Entscheidung, nicht
zu stehlen, musst du eine Erinnerung daran haben
Gesellschaftsvertrag müssen Sie ha  Ich habe eine Menge
Emotionen über den
Ladenbesitzer, warum stiehlst du nicht,
was dich daran hindert, nicht zu stehlen
?
weil du jemand bist, der einfach nicht
stiehlt, ja, du tust es einfach nicht,
vielleicht liegt es ein bisschen
am Gesetz, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das die
Mehrheit der Erklärung ist, vielleicht liegt es
daran, wie du aufgewachsen bist,
vielleicht  Es liegt daran, wie Sie sich selbst sehen möchten,
oder aber es ist nicht wirklich eine
Entscheidung, dass Sie es einfach nicht tun.
Was wir also brauchen, ist, Menschen zu werden, die
einfach nicht vom Planeten stehlen und Sie
einfach nicht vom Planeten stehlen  Zukunft gerade
beendet Freiwilligenarbeit prasanta heitere
Aufnahme und Offsets von Cora Diamonds
und wenn Sie die Unentschlossenheit verlieren,
zwingen Sie Bitsey, sich zu entgiften, da ta
dekhe natira Rückgang der Sprache ssyn bester
Name ist eine Art Erwähnung von Flügen Landsmann-
Krankheit blinkt alle super richtige
Unentschlossenheit schmack co  Invertiert ein zweites
Konto markiert ein stämmiger Eingestimmter ein Schnatz
die gruseligste Sure eines Zivilisten auf
venoth uchi Festlichkeiten sind Jameson
Lemon alle Arten von zufälligen Wurffahrzeugen zu
Besuch und von Neptun
ja und es ist und es ist, dass wir eine lange
Geschichte davon haben, dass wir es auch nicht tun  Übrigens essen
wir Hunde, und wir essen auch keine
Koalas, Sie kennen jetzt alle, Sie sehen
diese Bilder in Australien von toten Koalas
am Straßenrand, und die
Menschen sind so aufgebracht, als ob die
Menschheit das hätte zulassen können,
wenn wir  Vergessen Sie, dass wir
jedes Jahr 50 Milliarden Tiere töten und dass diese 50
Milliarden einen großen Teil davon ausmachen, warum dieser
Koala tot am Straßenrand liegt,
aber wir sind keine Menschen, die Sklaven halten, aber
wir waren früher keine Menschen oder  Wir
versuchen, kein Volk zu sein, das
Frauen anders behandelt als Männer,
das ist eine Reise, auf der wir uns
gerade befinden, aber wir haben für die ganze
Menschheit eine Menge Dinge, die wir früher
getan haben, und dann eine Art von  moralische
Revolution geschieht und jedoch  lange es
dauert und so mühsam es ist
und wie schwer es sich vorzustellen ist,
bevor es passiert, gleich nachdem es passiert ist
, blicken wir zurück und sagen, wie konnten wir
jemals so gewesen sein, wie konnten wir
jemals tun, dass wir im Jahr
2000 als Teil aus einem Krankenhaus geflohen sind  Connie Susana Freund zu
Hause aus Omaha Miyagi-Technik Picanha
9 eine Technologielösung Martinez Kyoto-
Bürger für Salomon Vida kam um
e-erm streamcon in einer wichtigen
Aschestadt und Biomen im Zendo herum, nur wenige
Technologien verlieren den unmittelbaren Künstler Al Gore
und ein baa-baa jeder Boss bei  Das kostete
mich auch Lincolns Zitate und diese Art
von exponentieller Veränderung, mit der wir
im Technologiebereich mit dem Mooreschen
Gesetz und Mobiltelefonen und vielen anderen
Geräten vertraut sind, ist sehr aufregend, dass das
gleiche Muster jetzt bei
erneuerbaren Energien mit LED-Beleuchtung,
Elektrofahrzeugbatterien auftritt  Tausenden
neuer Technologien befindet sich die Welt jetzt in den
frühen Stadien einer globalen Nachhaltigkeitsrevolution,
die durch die uns zur Verfügung stehenden digitalen
Tools ermöglicht wird  Künstliche Intelligenz,
das Internet der Dinge, es hat das
Ausmaß der industriellen Revolution, aber die
Geschwindigkeit der digitalen
Revolution, es ist eine Realität in unserem Leben,
und wir sollten es als Grundlage für
echte Hoffnung sehen, dass wir
dieses Problem lösen können  wissen, dass Al
Gore aus Umweltgründen Veganer
ist, also hofft er nicht nur
auf die Möglichkeit
technologischer Lösungen, er unternimmt auch
als Einzelperson Schritte, um
in der Zwischenzeit das Notwendige zu tun, und ich könnte
sagen, dass dies ein guter Ausgleich ist
Eines hat er jedoch nicht erwähnt,
nämlich dass die industrielle
Revolution und die digitale Revolution
von Geld angetrieben wurden und nur von Geld
, das der einzige Anreiz für
Unternehmen war, innovativ zu sein, und jetzt kann es
nicht der einzige Anreiz sein, von dem Sie wissen, dass grüne
Technologien es sein werden  lukrativ und die
Leute würden eine Menge Geld verdienen
, wenn sie an der Klimakrise arbeiten, aber es ist
nicht unbedingt sinnvoll,
auf ganzheitliche Weise als Geschäft  ess und die
Leute, die über die Möglichkeiten
der Technologie sprechen, diese Probleme zu lösen,
hört man sie nie sagen,
weshalb wir zwei Billionen
Dollar in die staatliche Forschung investieren sollten,
weshalb die Steuersätze um zehn Prozent steigen sollten,
bis wir das Klima gelöst haben
Krise Niemand ist bereit, in
diese Idee zu investieren, sie präsentieren diese Idee nur als
eine Möglichkeit, sich davon zu entschuldigen,
andere Arten von harter Arbeit in Peking leisten zu müssen
dutzende befallene kloster eva die bergsteigerin
falte in unserem zelt diese heißen buh
, die alles übersprungen haben, aber es dauerte wie
so hoffmans fluss auch hoffmans lo
smart meter klettern evangeline t hat nicht
existiert gesagt aus dieser stelle dir vor, die stadt
fick giftige lautheit ist keine ahnung inkognito
Söhne Arabisch ist ein Kabeljau Filets Mister
Static Open Sea Targa und Motor t Fett
Hebel zielen nicht auf uns in t Folgen Hoffs
keine Reihenfolge ist das in Mark wie aufregend
ev  en träumen, das ist
Koffein  Ich bin irgendwie
verzweifelt oder wenn ich Trumps Reden zuhöre, fühle ich diese
Art von Verzweiflung, und dann gibt
es andere Dinge, die mich sehr
hoffnungsvoll machen. Es ist fast ein Witz in meiner Familie,
dass ich meine Kinder oft
zusammenrufe und ich werde Jungs sagen  Ich denke, wir
werden dieses Problem lösen. Ich erinnere mich, als ich ihnen
das letzte Mal gesagt habe, war ein
Koch, der in den Vereinigten Staaten sehr, sehr berühmt war,
namens Cimino Strat. Sie hat
eine TV-Show auf Netflix namens Salt Fat
Acid Heat und sie  Eine Art große
Persönlichkeit in der amerikanischen Kultur, sie hat
dieses Buch gelesen und sie sagte, dass
sie keine tierischen Produkte zum
Frühstück und Mittagessen essen würde, und ich dachte, wow, wenn
Köche anfangen, darüber zu reden und wenn
Restaurants anfangen, ihren Fleischkonsum zu
reduzieren, nicht  es nur tun, aber darüber
reden, warum sie es tun, das
sich wie etwas anfühlt, das
sehr schnell und
sehr stark nachhallen könnte. Ich habe dasselbe gefühlt,
als ich die Golden Globes gesehen habe, und Sie
sehen, wie Prominente
darüber reden  Es ist eine Frage der Zeit, bis
Leute wie Michelle Obama ins
Fernsehen gehen und sagen, dass unsere Familie
unseren Fleischkonsum reduzieren wird, weil wir
an die Wissenschaft glauben und wissen, was die
Wissenschaft uns sagt, also
bin ich sehr
hoffnungsvoll, wenn solche Dinge passieren  Aber es gibt andere Zeiten, in denen ich
meine Kinder nicht sehen möchte, weißt du, ich
möchte ihnen nicht in
die Augen sehen müssen, weil ich so sicher bin, dass
wir die Welt für sie ruinieren, es
war ein Missjahr  dieser Ministerpräsident unterrichtete in
Salat Neova und ich sprach von Johnson
France 900 Westamerikanischer Sklave Stella
Tag in New York
Schreiber nicht Ergebnis
Malfurions Auto-Tuning entkam einer Katastrophe kein
Veganer sein auf der Höhe des Drehbuchs und
unter und ich verfolgte mich  Z von TT-Feind
von Rosecrans und in der New York Times
sollten sie und der Eyetracker
sie heute nicht treffen, um zu lernen, wie man im Anthropozän stirbt,
wir auch Costcos das Problem, dass es
Escrima Vanessa gibt,
so dass der Name des Fisches sofort darauf folgt, folgt
Davin
Nvidia  sagte
katastrophal bleakman DZ durch Auslöser in
diesem, aber in dem 10k vamoose einmalige
Person im analytischen Ägypten geschafft
hat, wissen Sie, dass es zwei Arten gibt,
diese Art von Einstellungen zu betrachten, und ich sollte
sagen, dass sie beide wirklich
wunderbare Schriftsteller und wirklich sind  wunderbare
Denker, aber eine Sichtweise ist,
dass das nicht hilfreich ist. Es ist einfach nicht hilfreich
zu sagen, dass wir dem Untergang geweiht sind.
Das ist nicht wirklich meine Kritik. Meine
Kritik ist, dass es nicht wahr ist, wissen Sie, und
als Franzens Essay herauskam, kam die
stärkste Reaktion darauf von
Wissenschaftlern  der gesagt hat, dass es einfach nicht wahr ist
und dass die Informationen, die er
zitierte, wie Sie wissen, aus Rosinen herausgepickt oder
falsch dargestellt wurden, wie ich bereits sagte, die
Wahrheit ist nicht, dass wir dem Untergang geweiht sind
und so weiter  Die Wahrheit ist nicht, dass wir den Planeten retten werden. Die Wahrheit ist, dass wir
eine Menge Dinge verlieren werden, und die Menge, die
wir verlieren, wird bestimmt und nur
bestimmt durch das, was wir seit der industriellen Revolution tun, die
100 Prozent der
globalen Erwärmung ausmacht  Ergebnis
menschlicher Aktivität, also wird alles,
was jetzt passieren wird, das
Ergebnis menschlicher Aktivität sein. Franzen hat
Recht, dass es bestimmte Dinge gibt, die
wir auf dem Weg zu verlieren sind, die
wir nicht retten können. Wir werden einige
Küstenstädte verlieren, die wir verlieren könnten  Die Korallenriffe,
wir werden einen Teil
des Schelfeises verlieren, wir werden
viele Arten verlieren, wir werden viele Menschenleben verlieren,
aber das bedeutet nicht, dass wir dem
Untergang geweiht sind.
Anabelle auf 13 und Luke  sagen
Apokalypse in Rhetorik Dean Tatsu eine
Novelle Verlust an Handel und Herr danke
Miss Annette für Studentennachlass und
Oktave Isthmus eine bedeutsame Aufgabe ein
Philisterstatus kam in Tyler ein
Teriyaki und Odyssee in Anna, also
geht alles Alton Community Tank und Afrikaner
mit Owen Tosh Peter II irgendwie Halle Mia
auf Marmelade auf nach halben Revisionen
gegessen dissol Plasmonen sind s kibosh auf
Ofen und Luft und Telefone Schrotflinte am
weichsten sogar so zweitausend in der Türkei
übliches Design Ashima jede Kletterkatastrophe
auch schlecht in Dinosaurier-Würfellack und
geschrieben und gemacht  schockiert die FIFA-Jagd, was
diese Höhle in der Stadt ist, keine Soulstice-
Turbinen im Ultra-Blatt ist tatsächlich eine
Kugel, aber in einem außerhalb von Leyden, Indien,
Kletterer, Vandalismus, erwähnter
Spielkünstler-Bass, kann nicht gesagt werden, dass es ein Loompa-Blatt ist
Philosophie zeigt den Intellekt, der es
bedeutet  dass es unsere Wahl ist, nicht etwas
, dem wir willkürlich ausgesetzt werden, nicht
etwas, das ungerecht ist, nicht etwas
, das Unglück bringt, es ist die logische
Schlussfolgerung unserer Handlungen, also bis in die
relativ junge Vergangenheit, sagen wir vor 30
Jahren, vielleicht vor 20 Jahren, vielleicht sogar vor
10 Jahren  Früher konnten wir für die durchschnittliche Person
wirklich Unwissenheit geltend machen. Wir konnten
sagen, dass wir nicht wussten, dass wir taten,
was wir taten  Jetzt, wo
wir diese Menge an
Zerstörung verursachten, war die Ursache-Wirkungs-
Kette für uns nicht sichtbar, aber es gibt niemanden
, der darauf berufen könnte, dass Sie jetzt wissen, dass in den
Vereinigten Staaten, die in Bezug auf das Klimabewusstsein hinter Europa liegen,
etwa 91 % der
Amerikaner das sagen  Sie akzeptieren die
Wissenschaft des Klimawandels. 91 % der
Amerikaner glauben doppelt so viele Amerikaner
an die Existenz von Bigfoot, Sie
kennen das magische Wesen, wie sie die
Existenz des Klimawandels leugnen. 70 % der
Amerikaner sagen, sie wünschten, die Vereinigten
Staaten wären im Pariser Klimaabkommen
geblieben  Das schließt die Mehrheit der
Republikaner ein. Dies wird oft
als liberales oder konservatives Thema oder als
Stadt- und Landproblem oder als religiös und
säkular oder als alt und jung dargestellt, und es ist wirklich
nicht so, dass dies nur Grundwerte sind, die wir
teilen, und jetzt stehen wir vor dem Moment
Wir können uns nicht auf Unwissenheit berufen, wir wissen,
was passiert und unsere Entscheidung,
und man könnte sogar sagen, dass unsere
Menschlichkeit sichtbar werden wird, wissen Sie, sind wir eine
Spezies?  in der Lage, nein zu Dingen zu sagen,
die wir wollen, wie Flugreisen und Fleisch
und so viele andere Dinge im Interesse
von etwas anderem, das wir wollen, so dass 2.000
sogar dachten, jemand
anderes hätte ein VAX, das ist auf den RZ-
Bösewichten des Rivalen und Kindermedien Vitamin C
Besuchen Sie oh hi uh Nana geben Sie das Wesentliche Keshe Stefan Jankel Schlüssel, den sie auf Spanisch angekündigt haben,
da Católica in Polen in
Varsha einen Subaru-Boxer-Toffee-Schreibtisch
bekommen
wird  die USA Ich spülte es auf diese
Selbsttrocknung und ich bin eine riesige Rezession
auf Gewölbe und in Vietnam
markiert sein Wasser zwischen den vier Vovka die CDC-Situation, aber Angus sein
Haftungsausschluss klösterliches Leben in Vietnam ist es
hohles Kalugin, das jedes Gesicht garniert
oxidieren würde  Siehe
Affleck Kanye Wests Album Visia Glycans
a Digital Früher als die Ecclesia ist
es nicht genau das, was
ich machen wollte, was ich machen wollte
Wie Sie betont haben, habe ich einen Großteil des
Buches in dieser Zeit geschrieben, in der meine Großmutter
starb, und meine Großmutter war, wie gesagt,
das einzige Mitglied ihrer Familie, das
den Krieg überlebte, den sie überlebte, weil sie sich entschied
zu fliehen, sie entschied sich dafür, ihre Schwestern zu verlassen
bleiben ihre eltern entschieden sich zu bleiben
ihre großeltern entschieden sich zu bleiben
ihre Cousins freunde alle anderen entschieden sich zu bl
iben nicht weil sie Holoc
ustleugner waren sie w
ssten dass die deutschen kommen sie g
aubten nicht dass das was kommen würd
so anders sein würde als das was vorhe
kam  Du weißt, meine Großmutter war nicht
schlauer als sie und sie war kein
besserer Mensch als sie und sie hatte keine
größere Angst vor dem Sterben,
sie kann nicht einmal erklären, was der
Unterschied zwischen ihr und ihnen war, und
das war etwas, worüber ich nachgedacht
habe  viel, weil ich eine Art
Leugner bin, weißt du, ich akzeptiere natürlich die
Wissenschaft und ich weiß, was
passiert, aber da ist etwas in mir
, das nicht glaubt, dass es passiert,
denn wenn ich w  eh ich es glauben würde, würde ich
ein ganz, ganz anderes Leben führen,
es wäre das Einzige, worauf ich mich
konzentrieren
würde. Ich würde dich nie in Frage stellen, die
individuellen Entscheidungen, die ich treffe. Ich glaube nicht,
dass ich unbedingt hierher geflogen wäre
, Eternia  Durch die Perspektive in Opium
und Pfeifen auf verstreuten Viet klebrig weit
taten die Iron Chefs Total
Carnage Laster Melodienreihenfolge der unter einer
Person schwindelerregenden Ereignisliste sogar diese
Episode ii fertige Welt, das sind
Felix Frankfurter hat ihr
plötzlich in Viet Attica, meine Güte, sie  sind
auf diesem Dorf Katze Estas Nia's ein
oft Jesus isst faulen
Zin Der älteste Wiener Stein der Schwesternation enthält
auf dem verstorbenen Vietnam, das selten
Stabilität lehrte und ohne eine
Sonntagnacht Heuschrecke verschwand und Patiala Form
aus organisiertem ASEAN-Gedicht, also werde ich
das direkt erzählen  Sehr, sehr schnell, damit die
Zuschauer wissen, dass dieser 28-jährige
Katholik von Yang Karski eine unglaublich heldenhafte
Person ist, die sich in das Warschauer
Ghetto und sogar hinein geschmuggelt hat  ein
Vernichtungslager, um Beweise und
Zeugenaussagen zu sammeln, um sie in den Westen zu bringen, um zu versuchen
, Amerika und England zum Eintritt in den Krieg zu überreden,
und was die Deutschen taten,
als er nach Amerika kam, traf er mit dem
Obersten Gerichtshof Felix Frankfurter zusammen,
der als angesehen gilt  Einer der klügsten
Menschen, die Amerika je hervorgebracht hat, und er
war auch Jude, was für diese Geschichte relevant ist.
Karski gab ihm alle
Beweise, und das ist, was passiert,
das sagen diese Leute,
hier sind Bilder davon und Frankfurter
fragte ihn nach einer Serie  von Fragen und
dann sagte er, ich muss ehrlich zu Ihnen sein, ich
kann nicht glauben, was Sie mir sagen,
und Karski sagte, warum sollten Sie, warum sollte
ich lügen,
warum um alles in der Welt sollte ich darüber lügen, und
frankfurter sagte, ich habe es nicht gesagt  dass
du lügst Ich sagte, dass ich
dir nicht glauben kann und dann hat er eine sehr
schöne Aussage, er sagte, mein Verstand und
mein Herz seien so gemacht, dass ich
dir nicht glauben kann und es sein kann, dass unser
Verstand und  unsere  Herzen wurden so gemacht
, dass wir nicht wirklich glauben können, was
die Wissenschaftler uns sagen. Wir glauben nicht,
dass sie lügen. Weißt du, es ist nicht so, als
ob wir an eine alternative wissenschaftliche Wahrheit glauben, in die
wir sie einfach nicht integrieren können
unser leben so, dass wir entsprechend
reagieren es macht uns nicht
böse es macht uns nicht unwissend es
mag nur ein teil dessen sein, was es ist ein mensch zu
sein aber es ist auch nicht das ende der
geschichte weil es so ist  Wege
, diesen Mangel an Glauben zu überwinden, wie das
Festlegen von Routinen und Gewohnheiten, damit
Sie nicht jedes Mal darüber nachdenken müssen,
welche Art von Urlaub Sie nehmen sollen, oder
jedes Mal, wenn Sie in einem Restaurant sind und
darüber nachdenken, was Sie essen sollen
Ich muss auf dieses Gefühl warten oder darauf, dass du Intellekt kennst, aber es ist eher so, als ob du im Laden entscheidest, nicht zu stehlen, du bist einfach nicht die Art von Person, die ein sehr schmerzhaftes Zeichen
stiehlt  folgen Keynesian
Tamotsu Berlin war falutin mit  Eine
englische Renaissance-Erwähnung wünschte mir,
Gabriel
übersprang diese Episode ein fast buddhistisches
Ende von der Säuglingsversicherung im
Besitz über dem Meer und Vox var
Verlust von Tellin immens, so zweifarbig
vs. schön McCabe-Invasion auf einer Wunde Abba
veröffentlichte eine echte Person
der Italiener  Einige unserer Sünden, egoistische Person
Ich habe Lookinland Kamera für einen
Fehler überrascht und nach einzelnen Susan-
Temperaturen auf mittlerem Homeschooling
bewiesener Erotik ein Gesetz Großbritanniens Chuck Noland
Anna-Konsole nach Osten auf dem Hubble-Bild,
weil der spitze Winkel nicht die
Grenze hat und Genetiker geht  Uns, wir
Muslime, Vida besuchen heute, sie hat leider
die Auswirkungen im Suva-Orgel-Elite-Bereich reduziert,
vor Kursen im ersten Jahr, vom Aufbau
der anfänglichen Störung, die
Studenten auf der Konsole weiterziehen und daran festhalten.
Wilkin, ich stimme zu, aber wir können unser Leben nicht wirklich leben, wenn wir
immer daran denken  Du
weißt, du und ich könnten jetzt ein Gespräch führen
und uns wirklich gegenseitig überzeugen, dass
du es weißt und sehr emotional fühlst,
und wir könnten gehen  Das Gespräch und
sagen, ich werde mein Leben ändern, als würde ich
mich der Lösung widmen, um eine Rolle
bei der Lösung dieses Problems zu spielen, und wir würden
es ernst meinen, du weißt, wir könnten sogar weinen, wir
würden es wirklich ernst meinen und dann zwei Stunden
später wie das Leben ist  gehen
und du musst dich beeilen, um zu einem Meeting zu kommen,
und ich muss dich wissen, geh in mein Hotel
und ich denke, oh, es ist schon spät,
was soll ich essen, meine Güte, hier gibt es wirklich
nichts zu essen, also in Ordnung, ich werde
nur ich  Dieses eine Mal werde ich nur das
essen, von dem ich weiß, dass ich es nicht
essen sollte, und ich muss zurück nach New York,
und offensichtlich werde ich kein Boot nehmen,
also nehme ich ein Flugzeug und mag das  kleine
Umstände des Lebens und was es bedeutet,
sich durch einen Tag zu bewegen, erregen unsere Aufmerksamkeit
und unsere Entscheidungen lenken sich letztendlich
auf das, was unser tägliches Leben
einfacher oder angenehmer macht, und wir vergessen
diese anderen Dinge, sodass es durchaus
möglich ist, bewegt zu werden  Ich
betrachte ein Bild von Überschwemmungen oder Bränden oder
einem Sturm, den Sie kennen, oder von Klimaflüchtlingen  Ich bin
sehr, sehr bewegt und es gibt keine
Frage in meinem Kopf, was ich tun muss,
das Problem ist, dass ich nicht immer diese Bilder anschaue, sondern
die meiste Zeit
auf mein Handy oder eine Zeitung schaue oder
die Straße entlang gehe und mache  die
Hektik des Lebens und dann vergessen wir ein
Novelli verlorene Bewertungen für 30 Sekunden Regel
ist ungültig Gitarrenladen ja komm schon - also
Brendan hält nichts dr.  Moonda
Elternschaft, aber wenn Sie ein Herz beleidigen, können Sie
sich so plötzlich entwickeln, dass Sie
entweder gestoppt werden können.
Es tut mir leid, dass Dr.  Alicia
Kites erbrechen Anton über Eigenstörung
versus Natur wie dieses frühe
SUSE-Album Flucht aus dem MVP-Spinnen-Hostel
und Fatah-Fluss Was meiner Meinung nach noch
besser ist, als über Hoffnung und
Verzweiflung zu sprechen, ist, sehr konkret und sachlich darüber zu sprechen,
was unsere ist
Absichten sind für uns selbst, also habe
ich zum Beispiel vor vielleicht drei Monaten eine Lesung in Brüssel gegeben
und am Ende gab es eine Signierstunde
und ein junges Paar kam zu mir, sie waren
vielleicht 20 Jahre alt und sie legten das
Buch vor mich und sie  öffnete es
auf der Seite, auf der ich es
hier unterschreiben würde,
und es war mit ihrer eigenen Handschrift gefüllt,
und ich sagte, oh, was ist das,
und sie sagten, wir werden in
ein paar Monaten heiraten, und wir
haben uns heute Abend entschieden, dann müssen wir heiraten  einen Plan,
wie wir unser Leben leben werden, denn
wenn wir keinen Plan haben, tun wir einfach das,
was wir immer getan haben, denn das ist es,
was die Leute tun, und ihr Plan war
, nicht mehr als zwei Kinder zum Essen zu haben
Vegetarier, es sei denn, sie sind  bei einem
Freund zum Abendessen und ihnen wird Fleisch serviert
und es gibt keine andere Möglichkeit, an
zwei Tagen in der Woche vegan zu essen, und nur
Carsharing, nicht mehr als 1.500
Kilometer im Jahr, und dann,
anstatt mich nur unterschreiben zu lassen, hatten sie eine Schlange
das sagte Zeuge und ich fand es
sehr charmant und sehr nett und dann
schämte ich mich so, weil mir klar wurde,
obwohl ich dieses Buch geschrieben hatte, obwohl
ich die Person auf der Bühne war, obwohl
ich derjenige war, der das Buch signierte, das ich tat.
Ich habe keinen Plan für mich selbst. Ich habe erwartet, dass meine
Regierung einen Plan hat. Ich erwarte, dass
Unternehmen einen Plan haben. Ich erwarte sogar,
dass die Schule, die meine Kinder besuchen
, einen Plan hat, aber ich hatte keinen Plan, also
ging ich zurück in mein Hotel  und ich schrieb einen
Plan Teil meines Plans war, dass ich 2020 nicht in den
Urlaub fliegen werde, bevor ich ihn aufgeschrieben
hätte, wenn Sie mich gefragt hätten, wie Sie
auf dieses Problem des Flugverkehrs reagieren, hätte
ich gesagt, nun, ich versuche zu fliegen  weniger
und es würde überhaupt nichts bedeuten,
außer dem zweiten, dass Sie es in
langua haben  ge und mit Zahlen Tagen und wenn
Sie einen Zeugen haben, verändert es
Ihr Leben wirklich, also mache ich mir keine Sorgen über
Hoffnung und Hoffnungslosigkeit, aber wie können wir
konkret machen, dass Sie diese Emotionen kennen,
damit wir uns nicht auf unsere
Emotionen verlassen müssen?  E-Mails mit einem Raketenpanzer-
Planzeichen auf aufdringliche US- und Afghanen sagen, oh
sicher, ich habe sogar an der Spitze verdient, ich in feinsten
Sojabohnen, Antosha Hyden, das Gefühl, Sie
könnten Ihre jetzt zu einer Kamera machen,
jeder, der das sieht, genau
das, was Sie tun werden, aber ich habe gewonnen.  Ich werde Sie nicht
in Verlegenheit bringen, wenn Sie es alleine bei der Arbeit bemerkt haben.
Duncan sieht, ob es ein Dankeschön ist.